take the i-515 expect some delays near
eastern over the next week the second
half of the eastern avenue bridge is set
to be demolished and it all starts
tonight joe muller gives us a look at
what to expect
you know that that's an elevated freeway
justin hopkins from nevada department of
transportation says the eastern avenue
bridge at the 515 is in need of repairs
those bridges need to come down and be
rebuilt parts of the elevated freeway
need to be readjusted and rebuilt
throughout the next week crews will take
down parts of the bridge the work will
happen at night and early morning these
are really going to be
primarily contained to the overnight
hours we're talking 11 pm to 6 a.m so
the traffic restrictions should be
minimal in preparation for the 40
million dollar project lane restrictions
on northbound 515 will be in effect
hopkins says there may be delays but the
work needs to happen really it's just to
ensure safety joe mohler live local now
a nine-day closure of eastern avenue
under the freeway will also take place
starting on january 17th